[Musique]
je des fois aussi enn de fiction dans
chose incroyable combattre des lions
dans dans des grands restaurants ce qui
aurait pu être le cas alors dans la
réalité difficile mais en chanson tout
tout est permis viens combattre lions
dans les grand
[Musique]
restaurant faire la révolution sur un
tapistherine est donc le chanteur de ces
lég
je suis pas un laborieux en
fait je m'ennuie très vite et puis le
travail c'est pas quelque chose qui qui
me tente vraiment donc mes chansons
viennent souvent dans des
[Musique]
rêves C deviner phine entre Charles tr
dernier eff pour le
[Musique]
c quand j'étais petit je voulais pas
être chanteur s passé comme ça j'aurais
pu être je pas géographe ça
[Musique]
me
céit au bout de la nuit